[Music]
foreign
Factor POI sharing with you the love of
poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and a couple weeks
ago I put out a feeler to find out some
POI tricks that people were really keen
on learning and one of my favorite
results was caps but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinsky and Becca
becklinen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so caps are not just one POI trick
they're a massive framework that
explains a whole lot of different things
that you can do with POI I did a video a
couple years ago exploring the many many
many different tricks that fall under
this umbrella that I'll go ahead and
link to down in the description but
today we are going to be talking
specifically about c-caps and more
specifically than that both the hands
apart as well as the hands together
version of this concept alright so
c-caps why do we call them that well
basically because our hand is going back
and forth across a c-shaped section of
space move my hand around from the
bottom out to top and then back out to
bottom basically you're just moving your
hand all the way up and all the way down
swiveling at the shoulder like so now
the trick is you're doing this with a
POI and you're keeping the POI spinning
the entire time so what this means is
one of these segments you wind up
performing an anti-spin pedal and the
other one you're performing an extension
on like so notice how I have the POI
kind of curling around itself as it goes
up and then going straight out in a
broad wide curve on its way back down so
we want to find ways of doing this with
both hands at the same time most
commonly this is done with the POI
spinning in opposites there are
variations of course where you can have
the POI and hands moving together I
don't think it looks quite as cool there
are applications for it though today
we're working with the versions that
have the POI spinning and opposites
though now we're going to want to do
this in wheel plane instead of wall
plane so rather than having both of the
POI together on the same side of our
body like this we want to have each POI
on each side of our body like their
wagon wheels turning on either side of
us that way when we look at it from the
side we can see the full profile of both
POI we're going to start off by doing
the hands apart version because I think
it's just a little bit more intuitive to
do that I want you to go ahead and get
the POI on your right hand side spinning
room reverse relative to you and the POI
on your left side spinning forwards
relative to you and you're going to get
the POI in your left hand spinning up on
high so your hands are apart I want you
to get your timing in Split time which
means that both of the POI are going to
be spinning back towards you through the
middle at the exact same time like this
if you want to see what that looks like
from the side here it is again I see
both of the POI coming at me at the same
time one of the ways that I kind of
think of this is that I am pulling the
POI back at me in unison so rather than
thinking POI up and down at the same
time I'm thinking pulling them pulling
them pulling them in order to keep this
timing together okay so next step is
we're going to slice our POI and hands
past each other like the jaws of an
alligator boom like so again we want to
try and get both of the POI pointed out
away from us for a second and then get
the right hand up high and the left hand
down low now please notice I did not
change the direction that either of
these POI were spinning they are still
spinning with the right hand POI going
reverse relative to me and the left hand
POI going forwards relative to me so
here's where it gets a little fun we're
going to have to do a little anti-spin
pedal in order to switch the right hand
down below and the left hand back up top
here's how we're going to do that I want
you to imagine that you're going to try
and push both POI away from you straight
forward boom like so and then you're
going to separate them out so that your
left hand goes up and your right hand
goes down again we push both the POI out
and then we pull them back towards us
with the left hand High and the right
hand low from here I want you to get
comfortable doing one two three beats in
the middle and then pulling them apart
again one two three beats in the middle
before pulling them back apart when you
can do 10 of those in a row comfortably
I then want you to go down to just doing
one two and back apart one two and back
apart and once you can do 10 of those I
want you to go down to just doing one
beat and pull them back apart
One Beat and pull them back apart when
you can do that you are doing the
anti-spin pedal well done all right now
let's put these two pieces together
shall we so I'm going to go ahead and
sweep across and then hang out for a
second one two three and then push
through that middle part one two three
sweep them back apart one two three push
them out one two three sweep them past
each other yeah then I'm going to try
going down to just two beats one two
push them out one two sweep them across
one two push them apart one two sweeping
back across and then we just do one beat
push one beat switch one beat push one
beat switch one beat push one beat
switch one beat push one beat switch all
right and now the challenge is to go
straight back and forth between the two
thinking push switch push switch push
switch push switch switch
so the thing that I most commonly see go
wrong when people learn this is that
rather than pushing straight out they
more push down so that the pedal and the
end of that motion are essentially right
next to each other like this now I
understand why it happens because it's
more comfortable than doing the full
anti-spin but at the same time it kind
of loses the effect so you really truly
want to think that you're going to push
straight out in front of you and then
come down again you might want to hang
out for just a couple beats with your
arms straight out before bringing it
down to get yourself used to that
position another problem I see a lot of
the time is that people will say do the
thing where they push out and then their
hands will just go straight up and down
instead kind of creating triquetras like
this you want to really see if you can
push your hands out far away from you
both when they're doing the anti-spin
side as well as when they're doing the
extension side think that you're kind of
doing the Monster Mash here yeah all
right now let's take a look at the hands
together version now the real challenge
here is that one hand is always going to
be doing the anti-spin pedal while the
other one is always going to be doing
the extension this is what we call a
polyrhythmic move and it results in
points of the move that feel like
they're in together time versus points
where it feels like the POI are in Split
time goes back and forth between the two
this makes it a useful transition tool
but also a little bit difficult to get
down so how exactly do we get it down
well the first thing to realize is that
now our hands are sweeping together both
going up and down at the same time it's
literally we just raise them both up and
bring them down the move still works in
wheel plane though all right so once
again with my right hand POI going
forward relative to me and my left hand
Point going reverse relative to me what
I'm going to try and do is I'm going to
try and push both POI out away from me
and bring them up near my ears now I
should have this visual check to see
both POI pointed away from me on the way
up alright so I'm I'm going to time this
off of the POI that is doing the
anti-spin pedal going either way so I'm
going to start off once again with my
right hand POI going forwards and my
left hand POI going reverse and with my
right hand POI I'm going to count off
one two beats going up again one two
beats one two as it goes up now the
trick here is going to be that as the
right hand is doing two beats the left
hand can only do one it's going to be
really tempting to have them both
performing Beats at the same time but
that's not really what we're looking for
so as we're doing that one two kind of
feeling I am trying to keep my left hand
POI straight out the entire way up and
on the way back I want to do the same
thing with my left hand POI I want to
count one two as it comes down and let
my right hand POI just sweep around and
drop again thinking one two as they both
come down now I'm going to give you a
trick for this one that at first is
going to seem kind of strange but I
actually want you to count out loud when
you're doing this going one 2 going up
and 1 2 going down the reason for this
is it's going to force you to slow down
as you're going back and forth between
these two positions and that's going to
make it more likely that you're going to
stay in control as you're doing it if
you find yourself in a position where
you're doing extra beats with the POI
that should be doing the extension
practice just working with that hand
alone a couple reps doing the sweep
going either up or down and then
immediately switching back into the
place where you're doing the count with
the sweep and it should help so we want
to think one two one two one two one two
going right hand to left hand two right
hand two left hand two going back and
forth back and forth like so and just
like the hands apart version it's not
unlikely that you're going to do this
thing where you're basically aiming that
anti-spin pedal really really close to
either end because well the anti-spin
just doesn't feel that comfortable yet
that's okay just to start with but as
you practice really dare yourself to
push the POI out in the middle to give
yourself that nice clean c cap shape
yeah so of course the gold star that
finishes all of this off is that you can
actually switch back and forth between
these two so as I am doing the hands
apart version of the cap note that when
my hands come together boom I can switch
into the hands together version and when
my hands are straight out in front of me
boom I can separate them out into the
hands apart version the hands apart
version is also really helpful for
switching into split time opposites
anti-spin flowers like so and the hands
together version is great not just for
switching into together opposites
anti-spin flowers but also it has that
point in the Middle where I can do the
split time opposites version two so it's
actually a really really useful
transition tool cool so this one wound
up being a fun one for me I hope it was
for you as well if you have requests for
other POI tricks that you'd like me to
teach lessons on let me know down in the
comments and I will do my best in the
meantime if you could make sure to leave
a comment like share and subscribe it
will help other people find the video
and it will help my channel grow so
thanks in advance
foreign
ly this video would not be possible were
not for the kind support of all of these
nice people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all so very much if you
would like to support me my work and the
channel here's how you can do that you
can sign up to become a patreon
supporter Yourself by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi or you can sign up for one
of my many courses over at mylearning
site at learn.drexfactor.com including
my beginner and Beyond Basics courses
that will take you through all the
beginner stuff as well as all the
intermediate stuff that will set you up
for success and finally you can take one
of my live stream classes I do these
every Tuesday night and I integrate a
lot of dance into it so go check that
out at crowdcast.io
drexfactor if you dug this video and
you'd like to check out more of my POI
lessons I will leave a link to a
playlist of said videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you're watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a
shout out as well there's also a link to
subscribe to my channel as well as to my
patreon so please check those those out
too thanks so much for watching and have
yourselves a good one I'll be back with
another video on POI spinning and flow
arts for you real soon peace